in the summer of 1954
the yangtze river flooded at least
30 000 people were killed in one of the
deadliest disasters of its kind in
history
the timing just five years after the
founding of the people's republic of
china
embedded in the tragedy an additional
layer of meaning
for the superstitious it was not a
cheerful start
to the revolutionary cause but rather
than let this become a stain
on the new nation mao seized the
opportunity to assert the party's
resilience
and depict nature as a common enemy to
be dominated
overcome and ultimately conquered
two years after the floods mao swam the
yangtze
in a triumph of propaganda to
commemorate this moment
the chairman wrote a poem in which he
dreamed of constructing a wall of stone
across the water
so great it would impress even a
mountain goddess
china's war on water had begun
the practical success of the many dams
and dykes built during the mao era
was mixed but the political success was
unquestionable
rivers are said to be the lifeblood of a
nation and the myths
surrounding them are ripe for nation
building
the yellow and yangtze rivers in
particular
are of special historical significance
the former
whose taming was arguably the foundation
of early government
is considered the birthplace of china
and holds over 40 percent of the
country's farmland
mao's preferred design for the new
national flag featured only a single
star and horizontal line representing
the yellow river
the yangtze river meanwhile is pictured
on banknotes
and is the center of rice production
textiles
and much of the nation's industry
control of
water has long meant practical control
of food
trade energy transportation and
protection against invaders
damning these ancient waterways was
therefore just as much
a testament to china's strength as it
was a means of managing water
engineering the environment led to the
perception of china
and more specifically the party as a
force
greater than nature one strong capable
and prudent enough to build something so
colossal
it was in this same light that 10 years
after his first swim in the yangtze
mao returned to affirm his grip on power
now 72 years old and facing a flurry of
rumors about his health
he once again used his association with
the river to demonstrate vitality
accompanied by six floating bodyguards
mao swam a whole nine miles according to
state propaganda
and in 2003 47 years later
mao's wall of stone was realized
indeed in the three gorgeous dam the
mighty gang sea
was finally conquered water
spawned chinese civilization control of
water
gave and later snatched away power from
imperial dynasties
and the state's engineering dominance
over water
showed the world what it was capable of
it is thus
rather poetic that someday very soon
water will once again play a defining
role
in china's future rather than suffering
from
too much water as in the floods of
decades past
today's china faces a different kind of
challenge
not enough of it and it will severely
inhibit the country's ambitions in the
past 20 years
28 000 of its rivers have disappeared
equivalent to the entire basin area of
the mississippi
the flow of the yellow river is now just
10 percent of what it was in the 1940s
making it the most threatened river in
all of asia
the number of dry ups has increased
rapidly
and that's just the beginning but don't
just take my word
take china's its leaders have called the
water shortage
a quote threat to the survival of the
chinese nation
announce the need to quote fight for
every drop of water or
die and its own ministry of water
resources
predicts a serious water crisis by 2030
sponsored by brilliant learn math
science and computer science
intuitively with a link in the
description
the problem facing china is not exactly
that it lacks
water make no mistake china has a lot
it's fresh freshwater resources are the
fifth highest in the world
behind only brazil russia the us
and canada two of which have the unfair
advantage of lying in polar regions
and measured by the length of all
navigable waterways
china is naturally blessed with the
number one position
more than twice all of europe combined
in fact
the problem slightly peaks its head out
when we adjust for population
per capita china's freshwater ranking
falls from
5th to 105th something like
2 000 cubic meters to the world average
of 8
000. still there are many large and even
rich countries
lower down on the list china's per
capita resources
are only modestly lower than the uk's
and
significantly higher than germany's one
of the reasons china's water scarcity
receives equally scarce attention
is that it's well hidden in
international comparisons
only when we ask where its water is
located
do we really begin to understand the
issue
when it comes to water china is split in
two
and the yangtze is an inexact but useful
artificial dividing line
to the south the theme is wet these
subtropical latitudes receive lots and
lots of rain
average annual rainfall in the region is
over two thousand millimeters
most of which occurs in the summer it
should be no surprise then that the
stable food here
is rice one of the most water intensive
crops
to the north of the yangtze think cold
and
dry this is a temperate to arid region
with only about 200 to 400 millimeters
of annual rainfall
there's some rain but not much just
barely enough to sustain
agriculture and noodles are the staple
the problem is not just where but also
when
the water is located even what little
precipitation the north
does receive it usually comes all at
once
making it even less useful than these
raw numbers imply
the same farm might contend with both
seasonal droughts and the crucial spring
months followed by monsoon floods in
july and
august and when one area experiences
one other areas are likely to
simultaneously experience the other
lack of water increases the
concentration of salt in the soil
and the hot summer months then pull
those salts to the surface
irregular and unpredictable weather
makes planning for these extremes
difficult to impossible and to make
matters worse
climate change is aggravating regional
differences
making the south even wetter and the
north even drier
this north-south divide is the
fundamental challenge facing china
lots of water below the yangtze not
enough
above it water of course is renewed in a
cycle
but natural laws do not obey the
economic laws of supply and demand
the two halves of china share almost
equal portions of gdp
industrial output and population except
the north holds only 20 percent of its
water
and the south 80. you might assume that
given this disparity
agriculture would be mainly concentrated
in the south
but not so 64 of
total arable land and some 40 of
farmland
is located in the inhospitable and
highly temperamental
north put differently the amount of
fresh water
per unit of farmland in the north china
plain
is 15 of the country's average
we think of china as the world's
producer
but the reality is that its ability to
feed even itself
is increasingly tenuous at best and
food is only the tip of the melting
iceberg
agriculture may account for the majority
of the national water usage
but the resource it should be most
fearful of is
energy it takes 24 bathtubs of water to
produce
one ton of coal and yet 86 percent of
its coal is produced in the north
it's true that china is actively
reducing its reliance on
coal but when it comes to water it
doesn't all that much matter
97 of its electricity requires water in
one form or another
and neither oil gas nuclear or hydro
power
is an effective solution so while
yes its reliance is decreasing over time
it's just not nearly fast enough and
because
household use is so miniscule in
comparison
water scarcity forces a trade-off
between energy
and food security neither of which is
palatable
nowhere is the situation more dire than
around the capital
beijing which makes the northern region
as a whole
look half serviceable recall that china
has
about 2 000 cubic meters of fresh water
per person
overall water stress is generally
defined
as just slightly less 1700 cubic meters
per person
scarcity starts at around 1 000 cubic
meters
and acute scarcity around 500.
here are the per capita water resources
in the country's 10 driest provinces
as of 2016 four were already below
half the level of acute scarcity the
worst
areas are in the same extreme category
as oman
pakistan and saudi arabia these are
chinese government-supplied figures
the high river basin which includes
beijing
is especially concerning thanks to the
stark contrast between its huge
population
and scarce water resources in 2016
the mayor announced that the city's
population could not be allowed to grow
past
23 million for this very reason it's
simply not sustainable
so far we haven't painted a very pretty
picture
but we've operated under a foolish
assumption
we've taken for granted that all water
is good water
which in china's case it most definitely
is not
the chinese water quality system has
five levels
level one is nearly drinkable two is
lightly polluted but treatable
three can be swam or fished in four can
be used only for industry
and never in contact with humans and
finally
level 5 is good for only one thing
irrigation
anything worse is essentially useless
already in 2013 over half of groundwater
around beijing was level
5 or worse just a quarter of the total
could even be treated for human
consumption
these days the vast majority of
groundwater is level four or
five and nearly one-fifth is worse
meaning
useless polluted drinking water presents
both an economic
and a human cost disease cancer
premature death
and immeasurable hardship environmental
degradation has caused the possible
extinction of the yangtze river dolphin
and desertification has led to beijing
sandstorms
so severe that they turn the sky a kind
of dystopian yellow
that is if you can see past the normal
pollution
given the absence of surface water in
the north cities have over-extracted
from underground aquifers
which carries several consequences first
draining groundwater so completely
leaves no backup in times of acute
stress
like during unusually bad droughts
second
removing aquifers causes the ground to
collapse
leading to subsidence which is when
buildings bridges and other structures
slowly and unevenly sink into the ground
shanghai for instance has sunk by two
meters
in the last two decades and more
embarrassingly
sections of the great wall are visibly
eroding
when the question of where to find water
arises
the inevitable answer is always
desalination
israel also starved for water has
effectively
solved its problem with six desalination
plants
which provide the country with about
eighty percent of its water
the difference between it and china
however is that the former is
tiny and rich it's estimated that to
desalinate and transfer one cubic meter
of salt water from the coast of china
inland would consume another 0.5 to 75
cubic meters of water in the process
desalination is extremely energy
intensive
china's energy comes mostly from coal
and
coal uses lots and lots of water
can you spot the problem well then
you might think the problem is really
only one of allocation
water can be moved so why not even out
the geographic differences
mao agreed in 1954 he observed
very matter-of-factly quote there's a
lot of water in the south but not much
in the north
if we could borrow some then everything
would be okay
it took half a century but mao's
suggestions
do not go unanswered the equally
straightforwardly named
south north water transfer project began
operation in 2002
the largest in the world it consists of
2
700 miles of artificial waterways and
canals
designed to do one thing move water
north the eastern route is a major
upgrade to the ancient grand canal
which pumps water from the yangtze up to
tianjin
the central route meanwhile is also
carried under the yellow river
but by gravity and all the way up to
beijing
a third western route is planned to
connect the tributaries of the yangtze
to the yellow river and will be the most
technically demanding
as its path intersects mountains there's
no doubt that the project which spans
four major rivers
three mega cities and six provinces is a
true
engineering wonder one could reasonably
argue that only
china has the unique combination of
political and economic infrastructure
to relocate entire towns coordinate
between such disparate levels of
government
and make the requisite legal changes at
this scale
this is not meant to imply that the
project was uncontroversial
expected to cost a massive 62 billion
dollars
it already exceeded that number a decade
ago and
345 000 people have been relocated in
the process
some are happy with their compensation
but others complain their new life is
measurably worse
the first drop of water meanwhile
reached beijing in 2015
seven years after the 2008 summer
olympics
the original goal now all of these costs
would be one thing
if the project singularly solved china's
water woes
unfortunately not even close even if it
supplied
only the beijing tianjin hubei area
these places would still be categorized
as acutely scarce
yet it's also responsible for three
other provinces
even at its imagined full capacity it
would only offset
one-fourth of northern china's annual
demand of 203 billion cubic meters by
2050
according to the chinese institute of
water resources
in other words decades of engineering
forced relocations
and environmental destruction all amount
to
essentially a band-aid perhaps
worse than a band-aid which may not heal
wounds but at least doesn't make them
worse these canals don't create water
out of thin air
they merely move it shifting the problem
quite literally
downstream southern provinces worried
about their own supply and quality of
water
increasingly rely themselves on water
transfer projects and dams from
elsewhere
when the music stops someone will pay
the price
all of this makes the enormity of the
project sort of
ironic on one hand it represents an
amazing technical accomplishment
on the other it represents the
extraordinary lengths china will go
only to paint the superficial veneer of
progress
the much more obvious solution is to
target not
supply but demand the price of water in
china is among the lowest in the world
less than a third of what it is in the
u.s and just a quarter of the world
average
because water is so heavily subsidized
farmers have little reason to make
efficient use of it
the most common method of irrigation is
flooding
when farmers aimlessly dump water over
their fields until most evaporates or
runs off
about half of the water used in this
process is wasted
these inefficiencies are reflected in
china's low water productivity
which is defined as the crop value
generated for every cubic meter of water
used various regional governments have
dabbled in market-based reforms
but not nearly as much as one would
expect given how much is at stake price
adjustments
are not to be clear some magical silver
bullet
but they do raise an important question
why did china spend a hundred billion
dollars building a water conveyor belt
from new york to la
when it could have just raised prices
some experts point to the curiously high
number of
engineers among china's top ranks many
even specialized in hydraulics
at one point all of the nine politburo
standing committee members were
engineers
it's probably true that hydraulic
engineers see everything as a hydraulic
engineering problem
and it doesn't hurt that the country has
historically sought high-profile
infrastructure projects as a means of
gaining legitimacy
but there's another reason one that has
nothing at all to do with water in
particular
the reason china opts for a band-aid to
solve its water crisis
is the same reason it waited decades to
halt the one-child policy
long past when its disastrous effects
were made clear
and the same reason it pays only lip
service
to the housing crisis there's one thing
china fears far far more than a
demographic
housing or even water crisis and it also
just so happens to be the key to
understanding its aggressive posture
why it seems to pick fights on the world
stage
and needlessly harm relations with other
countries
next time in part 4 of china's reckoning
while i was writing these videos i
remembered learning in school about
population pyramids
water conservancy and economics none of
it seemed very interesting to me then
and the only difference was how the
information was presented one of my
goals for this channel
is to inform and educate but in a way
that you
actually enjoy it's with that same
philosophy that brilliant is designed to
teach you science
math and computer science in a way
that's immersive and
engaging you learn with brilliance not
by memorizing formulas
but by doing and always in service of a
clear goal
lessons are designed more like
interactive games than lectures
take this one for instance in which you
learn science by doing
puzzles whatever you want to learn
python
statistics quantum computing or physics
brilliance got a course for you and you
can jump between them
whenever and however often you like
learn something new today by going to
brilliant.org
polymatter and signing up for free the
first 200 of you will also get
20 off the annual premium subscription